so little is known about the pics
searching for their Lost Kingdom means I
must follow every
lead and there's something on the walls
of this cave that's drawing me
in I'm going to start the scan okay yeah
my handheld Light Art technology allows
me to scan the walls and process the
data to separate the ancient markings
from the modern
right there's so many small subtle
details
here look at that
boom oh
wow look at
that and
then look at that yeah that's
it wow
wow is that what I think it is it looks
like that Crescent shape that you showed
me the symbol
Stone that's amazing it is a picture
symbol right
there wow that's
wonderful it's like finding new chapters
of a lost
story they're trying to tell us
something it's some kind of writing
system these intricate Stone carvings
tell me the pics were far more
sophisticated than the wild barbarians
the Romans
described there's got to be so many of
these all through this cave no there's
definitely more of them are you getting
this as we scan the walls we discover
even more ancient Clues and there's
another symbol just to the left of that
one each one a direct link to the
pictish people who touched these very
walls walls nearly 2,000 years
ago I can almost feel the presence of
the person who carved them it's not just
an image or a piece of ancient art it's
a window into the mind of the person who
made
[Music]
them I found
something
look there's something up there and this
rectangle with what is
that you know if you think um caves as
you know gateways Between Worlds it
could be a doorway from one world to to
the
next if it's a gateway to the other
world what's it doing
here I think they're memorializing the
dead the dead
yeah
when the first excavator visited the
cave to have a look at the carvings in
the late 1920s she found the the floor
of the cave strewn with human
bones this was a
graveyard amongst those bones were
nine vertebrae from the
neck and those nine vertebrae from the
neck had evidence for cut marks cut
marks made by a bladed weapon probably a
sword
up to nine individuals including two
teenagers were kids essentially children
yes were
decapitated right here right at the time
when the activity is happening at
denare that must have been a family
right nine people kids
adults and that downward strike of an
axe or a sword That's a classic Roman
execution style so we know that it
wasn't bodyless heads or headless bodies
that were entering the cave but it's
impossible to know exactly who killed
the people in this cave but what is
clear is that these traumatizing events
demonstrate the level of threat the
native tribes
faced what a place to
be
[Music]